un sorpresivo acercamiento entre China y
Ucrania el presidente chino dialogó
telefónicamente con su homólogo
ucraniano volodimir serenski el primer
contacto entre naciones desde el
comienzo de la invasión de Rusia tras la
comunicación el país asiático anunció
que un envío especial viajará
Próximamente A quién china enviará un
representante especial del gobierno
chino para asuntos euroasiáticos a
Ucrania y otros países y sostendrá
conversaciones con todas las partes para
resolver la crisis de Ucrania allí
selenski nominó un nuevo embajador en
suelo chino tras el llamado el cual fue
bien acogido por la comunidad
internacional desde Rusia hasta Estados
Unidos
he mantenido una larga y significativa
conversación con el presidente
creo que esta llamada así como el
nombramiento del embajador de Ucrania en
China darán un fuerte impulso al
desarrollo de nuestras relaciones
bilaterales
estos acercamientos de Beijing una
estratégico Aliado de Rusia sedante El
inminente Avance de la contraofensiva
ucraniana de primavera algo esperado
para las próximas semanas y que preocupa
las tropas del grupo Wagner el ejército
ucraniano está totalmente listo para
salir y cortar nuestros flancos nadie ha
cubierto nunca nuestros flancos todas
esas historias sobre impedir que las
reservas entraran en bakmut son pura
basura el ejército ruso no ha disparado
ni un solo tiro nadie les está dando
munición y a ellos ni a nosotros se dio
una orden criminal de no entregar
munición
se estima que se recrudezcan los
combates en la región de saporilla y en
la ciudad de bakmuth el principal
escenario de enfrentamientos en los
últimos 14 meses y que tiene el 80%
controlado por Rusia según el grupo
Wagner